so one of the things that really
surprised me today was you showed a
deleted scene
um from your episode which was I mean
obviously like again that episode is so
fantastic
um but that scene is so beautiful and
great and it kills me that it's only
going to be seen in this room can you
sort of for people that weren't in the
room can you sort of talk about what the
what that scene was and um what it meant
to you yeah so the scene that that was
shown here that was deleted which by the
way I had kind of forgotten about
because it was such a long time ago so
it was really nice for me to see it and
it felt brand new again but it was a
scene where it's a continuation of of
myself and dream walking and talking
through London and you know he's going
about he's with me on a day of work
right he's like you know bring your kid
to work day
um and um in that scene what we talk
about is you know death goes through her
job and and she expects what she does
obviously get resistance and so what she
talks about is she decided to explain
experience what she does so she lived
for a day and then met herself you know
she was she was taking it she she had
her amount of time and um
I think that uh that scene or that that
part that we were taking from the comic
is so key to who death is in the reason
why she's so compassionate is because
she understands because she went through
it so she understands that no one is
ready at the end because she herself
being deaf and knowing what was going to
happen still didn't feel ready to go
it's about a fantastic scene I really do
hope that Neil and people reconsider